we wanted a closer look at the facts
behind the story and so we spoke to the
acting ice director Thomas Holman just a
few minutes ago here's part of it mr.
Altman thank you for joining us you've
heard prominent people compare your
behavior to that of the Nazis to that of
the Roosevelt administration and turning
the Japanese to bring world war ii how
do you respond I think it's an insult to
the brave men and women aboard with tow
and ice to call law enforcement officers
and Nazis they're simply enforcing laws
enacted by Congress you know I wish
there's this much outrage about
separation of families I wish I heard
this much outrage and we met with angel
mothers and fathers who children were
killed by illegal aliens Jewish citizen
children killed and separated from their
families forever I never heard this
outrage so I think people on the hill
you need to straighten himself out there
let's protect American citizens that
much as you're fighting for the illegal
alien what we're about to speak to the
parent of one of those children killed
in the way you described did you notice
cable news anchors or Democratic
politicians swooping in to comfort those
families when their kids were killed no
I didn't you know III that the median
last few days I've been sensed by the
purposeful the intentional misleading of
the American people by politicians and
they say that Trump administration wants
to use these children of political pawns
the Trump administration isn't down
there having political sideshows with
these children and talking about this
issue
the term administration wants Congress
to fix this and Congress has the
authority fix it
but what we wouldn't know is talking
about it's an underlying reason for this
whole argument are these families really
escaping for your in persecution the
immigration court has said in last
year-and-a-half
over 80% of these claims are frivolous
so first of all we got attack the very
foundation they're arguing these people
are coming to this country these parents
themselves are using these children as
pawns to gain entry to the United States
knowing that we can't detain them and as
far as the separation of families are
concerned you have to put the blame on
the parents they are choosing to enter
between the ports of entry they know
they will be separated but they want to
blend the government when we were forced
to do that so let's put the blame where
it lies not on the fine men and women
the Border Patrol ice we're enforcing
the law
what would happen we don't make the
policies of course what would happen if
we do what we're hearing we must do and
that is give immediate automatic amnesty
to anyone crossing illegally with a
minor child in tow what would happen let
me talk that's what's been done that's
what we're asking Congress to fix the
floor settle agreement to let me tie the
way it works right now under force L of
agreement if a family comes into our
custody we can hold them for less than
twenty days we release them most of the
most open immigration court immigration
court last year issued over 40,000
orders an abstention that means these
people didn't show up so what we want to
do is have Congress change of law to
keep these people detained in a family
setting so the case can be heard by a
judge I would think everybody regarded
through Republican a Democrat wants your
cases heard but because you don't like
the final decision doesn't mean we
forget about it because last year we
actually went to look for these families
we got final orders an abstention I got
hundreds of letters saying how dare you
put your finite resources with the women
and children I'm like wait a minute you
wanted to have due process of great
taxpayer expense
because you don't like the decision
let's forget about it I thought we work
mr. umin thank you for joining us
senator she ate it
I appreciate you sir